you were right about me all along mr.
camp I am the villain of the story ham
it's my boyfriend - stop hey you look
smart custom urine excuse me yeah judge
spells Queen urine on ebay so people can
pass their drug test sounds illegal
ah moral gray area but totally paid for
gold thunder over there yeah it's nots
really cool to come with the ring
constraint you asked your underpants
that question please why you are
involved in a homicide
all right and I am NOT leaving without
Divya nanos with a golf club I didn't
think it would hurt her fast Brad Davis
is Nelson your addressing he is him [ __ ]
is going on here my bras rubbing me
wrong I have a fat ass I've twisted my
ankle three times today
bills are oh they make my legs look
slimmer I have a fat ass
your ex is a guy like after we're
lesbian yeah what's with the Louisville
Slugger
where'd you join the old deck softball
league alright now that you're wired
right now no no no Steve look or not I
don't work you know it sound like an
appreciator you don't seem gay make no
mistake I like [ __ ] before you get my
money there's something I want you to do
it's lovely
[Music]
you're moving to Los Angeles with the
man you barely know angle hold on a
second I'm not letting you put 500 miles
away with a man named Charles Bronson
you barely know who happens to be in the
witness protection from first of all I
never should have told you anything
about it
I never said it secondly you don't have
the authority to not let me do anything
guilty do you disappear with that
scumbag a right is unacceptable it's
probably a murder you enroll play with
your core give me the album wolf I just
wanted to be sure that everyone was
alright you all right there
Sani okay hey she just said she was
alright
why is this any of your [ __ ] business
Mike I had some experiences I'm a
Deepika would you care to explain to the
jury what you mean by that out of it
it's wrong
I would say so are you happy so you
think who really knows that they're
happy or not
well happy people I guess look [ __ ] I
don't know who you think you are this
isn't a multiple choice question
alright now there's a simple answer and
you're gonna give it to me hey easy mate
I have got a multiple choice question
for you
[Music]
[Applause]
so much